un parent vers une ère industrielle plus
verte le canada et l'allemagne signent
un accord sur l'exportation d'hydrogène
le but alimenter les normes machines
industrielles allemandes d'ici quelques
années ce vote de confiance envers
innovations canadiennes et nos
travailleurs et c'est un vote de
confiance dans l'avenir du canada comme
leader en matière d'énergies propres
objectifs et d'exporter de l'hydrogène à
faibles émissions et ses dérivés vers
l'allemagne a compté de 2025 et de
mettre en place une chaîne
d'approvisionnement transatlantique
complète avant 2030 rien donc pour aider
l'allemagne à se sevrer de l'énergie
russe à court terme atlantic canada
présente une opportunité grâce les
leaders ont choisi une péninsule de
l'ouest de l'île de terre-neuve pour
leur annonce un endroit où doit voir le
jour une usine qui utilisera l'énergie
éolienne pour produire de l'hydrogène
vert dans la première phase jusqu'à 164
éoliennes devraient être construites un
projet majeur mais à l'échéancier serré
le canada a beaucoup à faire pour
respecter ses objectifs la brindille
tuyaux d'été viennent pour les
transporter sa part des terminaux pour
les mettre à la masse ou delà des
infrastructures à bâtir il ya aussi
d'autres incertitudes
quelle sera la demande pour l'hydrogène
canadien dans quelques années est-ce que
des milliards investis dans nos
infrastructures intra tendent à dans une
optique temporel de 10 15 20 ans ou
est-ce que l'hydrogène sulfuré pardon
d'énergie donc c'est ici de paris et
d'apprendre les provinces du canada
justin trudeau crois que l'hydrogène est
une option viable au moment où plusieurs
pays cherchent des solutions de rechange
à l'énergie russe l'invasion est
justifiable la russie de l'ukraine a
changé la donne de façon
profonde et à accélérer un processus qui
allait peut-être prendre encore
plusieurs années peut-être une décennie
avant qu'on fasse un flipper hydrogène
au delà du rapprochement avec
l'allemagne cette entente représente un
test pour terre-neuve-et-labrador une
province productrice de pétrole qui
cherchent à se tourner vers les énergies
renouvelables tout en créant de bons
emplois spécialisés ici louis blanc
radio-canada stephenville à
terre-neuve-et-labrador